[OPENING MUSIC PLAYS]
MAN #1: So one of
the things that
would be really useful
to have, I think,
is an operating manual
for human beings.
Like literally, if
we could figure out
a set of instructions,
a set of algorithms
that would teach us how
to optimize ourselves,
how to tweak the knobs and
levers of consciousness
towards useful spaces,
of contemplation,
and transformations so that
we may become more than what
we are-- so that we may
expand, transcend, transform.
And there's a wonderful
idea popularized
by Kevin Kelly, known as
Finite and Infinite Games.
Now Finite and Infinite Games
is a book by religious scholar
James P. Carse.
And Kevin Kelly, who
co-founded Wired Magazine,
has praised it for "altering
my thinking about life,
the universe, and everything."
And, essentially, it
comes down to this.
Finite games are
played to win or lose.
Right?
That's familiar.
That's boring, right?
Infinite games are played
to keep the game going.
take note of this idea.
It is no longer about
black and white.
winning or losing.
The clue here is to
keep the game going,
to reach a kind of
cosmic homeostasis,
to move to spaces beyond
entropy, beyond death.
It's not about
conquering, it's about
continuing to exist,
to contemplate.
It's about immortalizing and
internalizing consciousness.
The futurist Ray Kurzweil
has popularized the term
singularity as the moments in
which humans transcend biology.
Jesuit scholar Peter de Charin
talks about the omega a point
and the directionality
of evolution.
Others have written about
the fact we decommissioned
natural selection,
and now we get
to look deep within ourselves
and actually decide,
author what we wish to become.
We are a geologic force.
Now, we've seen
how this power can
be used in destructive ways.
We've seen the effects
of global warming,
but we must also realize
that we have unique capacity
with this new construction
kids for all reality to,
not just address the grand
challenges of humanity,
but essentially
to fix the world.
Not to win or lose, but
to keep the game going.
So let us say this, right?
Let's stop playing
the finite game.
Let us play the infinite game.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS]